[Música]
actualizamos la información económica
con Juan Pablo lucumí Juan Pablo saludo
nuevamente acá estamos otra vez Ángela
hoy se conoció otro informe importante
Juan Pablo que nos muestra que las
potencias mundiales se arman cada vez
más en lo que se refiere a lo militar
Así es un informe que cobra importancia
porque como humanidad superamos la cifra
histórica del gasto militar mundial
alcanzando los 2,24 billones de dólares
en 2022 según el reporte del instituto
internacional de estocolmo para la
investigación de la paz el informe
señala que además de llegar a este
récord es el octavo año consecutivo que
el gasto militar crece el reporte
también muestra que el mundo está
retrocediendo a épocas de la Guerra Fría
cuando luego pues Europa y occidente y
Europa central y occidental superaron el
gasto por primera vez desde 1989 con
datos 30% mayores a los registrados en
también se conoció Quiénes fueron los
que más gastaron y vamos a revisarlos
específicamente en el siguiente gráfico
vamos a ver el orden Estados Unidos Pues
toma la delantera o más bien siempre ha
estado en este puesto con 877 millones
de dólares el segundo puesto es para
china quien tiene 292 mil millones de
dólares y en el caso de Estados Unidos
representa el 40% del gasto general y
como puede ver pues hay una diferencia
muy grande entre el primer puesto y el
segundo puesto el tercer puesto sería
entonces para Rusia con 86.400 millones
de dólares esto en el marco de la Guerra
de Ucrania el cuarto puesto quedó para
India y Arabia Saudita el último puesto
o el quinto más bien de este top con los
75.000 millones de dólares Pero entonces
cerramos este tema con una de las
conclusiones a las que llega uno de los
investigadores de este informe que la
vamos a leer a continuación abro
comillas y dice el continuo aumento del
gasto militar mundial en los últimos
años es una señal de que vivimos en un
mundo Cada vez más inseguro los estados
están reforzando su fuerza militar en
respuesta a un entorno de seguridad en
deterioro que no prevén que mejore en un
futuro próximo y por si nos quedaba
dudas Pues ahí está el dato de Estados
Unidos y de su influencia a nivel
mundial así es Ese es claro Es evidente
no pero bastantes que supera muchísimo a
los datos de los demás países en el
gasto no completamente Bueno vamos a
cambiar de tema este lunes dio a conocer
el que podría ser uno de sus últimos
informes desde resultados financieros o
cuál es la cifra que usted nos destaca
de este informe otra de las grandes
cifras de este lunes son los 68.600
millones de dólares que perdió en
activos el banco suizo en el primer
trimestre de este año y según sus
autoridades las salidas de esos activos
continúan mientras nosotros estamos
hablando aquí los depósitos de los
clientes también se redujeron en cerca
de 75 mil millones de dólares todos
estos datos antes del rescate de
emergencia de su competencia el banco
local vs la mayoría de las salidas de
esos activos procedían de su división de
gestión patrimonial y se produjeron en
todas las regiones sin embargo Angela
las acciones de greates tuvieron leves
ganancias en las primeras operaciones
del mercado pues algunos analistas
señalaron que las salidas no fueron tan
malas como se temían el banco de 167
años de antigüedad informó los
resultados que podrían ser su último
informe ya que se espera que pronto pues
se consume el rescate del banco por
parte de su rival el vs ya veremos pues
cuánto le toca rescatarlo no en otros
temas qué dolor de cabeza Twitter Juan
Pablo todos los días hay cambios de
rumbo que confunden además a los
usuarios ya uno entra y no sabe si lo
que está viendo es una opinión informada
o simplemente una persona que pagó por
Mostrar su opinión como informada en las
últimas horas algunas personas
recuperaron la marca azul pero no hay un
pronunciamiento oficial de la compañía
no hay pronunciamiento oficial y no se
sabe tampoco Cuáles son las cuentas por
qué regreso esta marca pero lo que se
estima es que son cuentas de mayor más
de un millón de Seguidores pero ya
veremos qué pasa cuál sería como la
verificación oficial porque varias de
estas cuentas de grandes Ya recuperaron
esa marca azul que antes se mostraba que
era una cuenta verificada pero que
después de que pues llegó elon musk
ahora es para aquellas personas que
hacen parte de un programa en el que
tienen que pagar 8 dólares para tener
esa pequeña Estrellita Azul al lado de
su nombre varias de las personas a las
que se le regresó esta marca dijeron que
no han pagado la suscripción incluso la
verificación regresó a personas ya
fallecidas como el basquetbolista Kobe
Bryant No qué locura completamente pero
veremos Entonces qué sucede si hay una
verificación o que Cuál es el
pronunciamiento de Twitter Sí pues que
nos digan porque Twitter antes era
considerado como una red social muy útil
No muy muy buena para solucionar dudas
que uno tenía y opiniones Como le decía
informadas que se necesitaban ver ahora
pues no sabemos vamos a los indicadores
pues hace pocos minutos se conoció que
Walt Disney comenzará una segunda ola de
despidos este lunes mientras trabaja
para eliminar 7000 puestos de trabajo
buscando ahorrar 5.500 millones de
dólares en costos eso según Fuentes
familiarizadas con el asunto y también
la agencia routers podemos ver en
pantalla que los tres indicadores
abrieron en positivo las bolsas en
América Latina cerraron el viernes en
mixto con el indicador de Buenos Aires
reportando una importante ganancia del
3,21% México y Colombia reportaron
pérdidas y Sao Paulo no operó ese día
porque pues era día festivo Juan Pablo
Le agradezco mucho y nos vemos mañana
mañana con más información acá lo espero
feliz día gracias